-You know, I love asking
about your mother every time
you're here.
Last time you were here,
we talked about
how you were renovating
her house for her.
-Yes.
-And you just --
you were filming the show
in London.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you had her come to London.
-Yeah, my family,
they find a way to come
wherever I'm filming.
And it's never just one.
It's my mom, my stepdad,
my aunt who lives next door,
my sister, my brother-in-law
my niece,
my brother and his girlfriend.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-All of them.
-It's a lot of people.
I feel like that is not --
I mean, you have a photo here.
-Yeah, well,
so when they came to London,
I really wanted it to be
special.
They'd never been in London.
And you'd think that
one of them was dying.
Because they literally
went to Kensington Palace
and Wimbledon three times,
met Serena Williams.
I mean, this is --
This is where they meet her.
-That's proof they met
Serena Williams.
-Yeah.
They -- we did everything.
And I actually --
I tried to make it really
special, like I said.
And one day, I actually
rented this double-decker bus.
And I invited some of the cast
and my family
and some friends were in town.
And now the thing about my mom
is she's obsessed with
Chinatowns across the world.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-And she really wants to g
and see if every Chinatown
is just like
all the other Chinatowns.
-Okay.
-That's all she wants is jus
to see if it's the same.
-Does that make her happy
when it's the same?
-It makes her --
Yes, makes her very happy.
-So she likes the consistency.
-Yes.
Yes, she's like, "Ah, yes.
Like, almost like we've
taken over, you know?
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-And so we get
this double-decker bus,
which is not cheap, you know
And it's just --
just us on this bus.
And so we're going around to
see the most amazing places.
And there's Big Ben.
There's Kensington Palace.
We get out, take pictures.
We're doing all this stuff
But the entire time my mom
just keeps asking, like,
"Where's Chinatown?
Where's Chinatown?"
And so a few hours into
the -- into the trip,
we get to this crossroads.
And the bus driver says to me,
like, "Hey, so here's the thing.
If we take a left,
we're gonna continue going o
and seeing -- there's a lo
of amazing historical site
that the we can go see.
But because of traffic,
we can't really
come back around.
So if we take a left,
we can do that.
But if we take a right,
I can drop you off
and you can go to Chinatown.
[ Laughter ]
Now, he's like, "And I just --
I've been hearing your mom
talk about Chinatown."
He's like, "So, I don't really
know what you want to do."
I said, "Let me go talk to her."
So I said, "Mom, okay,
we got a few more hours left
on this amazing trip.
Now, if we take a left,
we can go see all these
amazing historical sites.
It's like, you know,
hundreds of years old.
And this is London. And there'
gonna be so many amazing things.
Or if we take a right,
we got to get off
and then we can go to
Chinatown."
And she goes,
"Chinatown."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Okay."
But when we -- That's --
Oh, yeah, that's us on the..
-I mean, that is --
-...the bus.
-That looks like a --
That's the way to rock it righ
there.
-That's us on the bus.
-That's amazing. Yeah.
-The entire time, this is her,
"Chinatown. Where's Chinatown?
-Gotcha.
She's -- she's smiling because
Chinatown's over here.
[ Laughter ]
So she's looking at Chinatown.
-She's like, "That's it."
-Yeah.
-But here's the best part.
When we get there,
we get off the bus,
say goodbye to the driver,
who's very perplexed
at this moment.
He doesn't understand.
And we walk into Chinatown
My mom looks around
and goes,
"Same."
[ Laughter ]
And then about --
I'm not kidding,
like 15, 20 seconds later,
she's like, "Let's go home."
And that was it.
[ Laughter ]
She just wants to go there
to be like,
"Is everything in order?
Is everything where I put it?"
-That's so great.
Well, at least Chinatowns
are not like McDonald's.
You know what I mean?
-That's true. But although
I realized after this trip
if that's what matters to her,
we could stay local.
We can go to Iowa, you know?
We can go to Michigan.
We can go to all the just
domestic Chinatowns.
We don't have to go across
an ocean.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Let's go see all
the American Chinatowns.
Why are we doing this?
-Yeah, when you get on
a British Air flight,
you feel like, they're never
like,
[ British accent ]
Let me guess. Off to Chinatown
[ Laughter ]
Taking a trip
to see our Chinatown?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I wish --
You know, your family
is so sweet.
I mean, your family's so close
Your mom and dad, your brother
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
-You guys are all so close
I feel like when you guys go
places,
it's -- you know, you guys -
you and Alexi
go on just the most amazin
vacations.
-Yeah.
-It's very --
My family would go to
amazing places.
And then we just go to
Chinatown.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Well, with my mom,
I would say it's -- instea
of Chinatown, it's just a bar.
[ Laughter ]
She's telling the bus driver
like,
"Are we going to see any bars?
[ Laughter ]
-He's like, "We passed a bunch."
Yeah, any one will do.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She like's -- you know,
she's like, "I want to
look at the bars."
-And your family loves karaoke
I know that.
-No.
-No?
-My wife's family loves karaoke.
-The wedding, I felt like your
mom and dad were really into it.
-Yeah. We were, but again --
-To be supportive
of the in-laws?
-Yeah, we were supportive
of the family.
-Do they love country musi
as much as we do?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause his wife's family love
country music, and so do I
-Yeah, and my wife's famil
has an actual karaoke --
You've seen it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Like a karaoke setup.
-Yeah, I've been to New Mexico
at his wife's family home there.
And it's the moment you get in
it's karaoke.
-Yeah.
-The moment you get in.
-It speaks to how much I love my
wife that I've looked past that.
[ Laughter ]
-She's amazing.
And so --
My in-laws are amazing.
But when my father-in-law --
my father-in-law sometimes
will just --
I will come downstairs.
And he'll be sitting outside
singing karaoke to himself
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No. It's just --
when I came to visit,
I came out late at night
to get some water.
And he's in there by himself
in the dark.
-Yeah.
-We just the words coming up
on the screen just --
[ Laughter ]
He's really giving everything.
-And then he'll make something
up like,
"It's the only way to keep awa
the coyotes."
You're like, "No, it's not
[ Laughter ]
You're doing this
'cause you love the sound
of your own voice."
This is a really cool show
-I'm excited.
-You shot it in London.
-Yeah.
-And you play
a government agent.
-Mm-hmm.
-Did you do any research
for your government agent work
-My -- well, you know,
I just came off the show
called "Six" where I playe
a CIA operative.
And this -- this show --
"The Rook" is different.
It's not where -- it's
a made-up, you know, agency.
But we are spies.
And I'm the only American in
the whole show, in the cast.
So I was able to bring
some of that, you know,
experience just from
that show into this one.
-There's some supernatural
elements in the show.
Are you -- Do you buy
into the supernatural?
I don't know.
-You don't. Do you?
-No.
-I know.
I can tell by the way
you say it.
-Yeah. "Do you buy in?
I feel like --
No. I don't.
-Do you buy in -- like,
do you feel like you waste
your time with that?
[ Laughter ]
-That felt like
a very different question.
-No, no, no. I'm just curious.
I mean we all waste our time
different ways
and, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-I'm trying to figure out
how to answer this.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I -- I believe
in the science of things.
-Yeah.
-And I believe that
we don't know everything.
But I don't just --
I'm not just a believer
who just --
I don't believe in everything.
I just don't go, like,
"Oh, there's a medium.
I'm going to go find this
person. There's a psychic.
I don't believe in that.
But I believe in
the science of things.
Is that vague enough?
-Yeah, that's getting vague.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah. Well, for example,
my brother right now,
he's getting his PhD in physics.
And he and I talk a lot abou
just science and stuff.
And my family,
they're very analytical,
and they're like you.
They don't -- they just --
They're like,
"If it's not science based
we don't believe in it."
But my brother talked to m
once about the color blue.
So we're talking about
a friend who loved blue.
And he goes,
"Oh, that makes sense.
Because it has a really high
vibration, high frequency.
I'm like,
"What are you talking about?
He's like, "Well, you can
measure colors."
He put out a --
He's getting his PhD in physics.
I feel like you're not nodding
but not believing me.
I feel like you're doing
this thing. "Uh-huh."
-I didn't know -- the part o
this story that's crazy to m
is like, "We were talking
about a friend of ours
who loved blue."
I'm like, "is he 6?"
[ Laughter ]
How does it even come up?
A friend at dinner being like,
"Have you guys seen the ne
blue?"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's --
and you know this friend.
And it was --
and the reason I brought it up
was because I thought
it was just so strange.
-Yeah.
-Everything had to be blue
-Yeah. Oh, gotcha.
So, it's like an obsession
-I was like -- Yeah, I was like,
"Hey, it's so weird.
Everything has to be blue.
-Yeah.
-"Head to toe blue.
Couch is blue."
-And so blue vibrates.
So that's --
-And he was like, "Well, maybe
it's because, you know --"
He's like, "It makes sense
if he's, like, vibrating
to the color blue."
And then I was like,
"Oh, well that's an interestin
thing of just colors can put out
an actual frequency that
scientists can measure."
So, I mean -- can we just
cut this whole part out?
And just me go --
I'll just be like,
"I don't believe in it either,
Seth."
-No. I, like --
Yeah, sure, we'll cut it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I mean,
my brother's gonna call me
I know my brother's
going to be like,
"That's literally
not what I said."
But I feel like -- I think
I translate in my head --
-I feel like your brother
is a scientist.
And he's like, "Hey, Olivia.
I know I just told you this.
But, like, you don't know enough
to go tell someone else."
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
But he told me this years ago.
And it's most likely gotte
wrong in my head multiple times.
-He talked to you
for an hour straight.
And you were like,
"Blue, vibrates, got it. Bye!"
[ Laughter ]
I have to go to a TV show now.
-Yeah. "I'm gonna go tell Seth
all about this."
-I want to talk about
your dogs real quick.
-My dogs. Yeah.
That's Chance and Frankie.
-Gracie and Chance.
-Chance and Frankie.
[ Audience awws ]
I think you were thinking of -
-And what did I say?
-Grace.
-I said Grace and Frankie.
-'Cause I think that you'r
thinking of the show with --
-I am.
-Yeah.
-It's a great show.
-Chance and Frankie is ver
close to Grace and Frankie
-Yeah, it's super close.
-It is.
Jane Fonda almost
was named Chance.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-But I've seen this
all over town.
It's a lot of billboards
in New York.
Tell us about this
great organization.
-Well, this is great.
This is the Shelter Pet Project.
And it's with the Humane Society
and Maddie's Fund.
And we're --
you know, the three of us,
we're trying to get people
to adopt shelter animals.
'Cause there's --
I mean, these are --
These two pups, okay.
He's a Cavalier King Charles
It's purebred,
yet he was in a shelter.
This kid was on the street jus
living life, living large.
And now they're on billboards.
I mean, how cute is that?
-I feel like that breed, lik
being a Cavalier King Charle
in a shelter is like when
a rich person gets locked up
they're like, [ Uppity accent
"Do you know who I am?!
[ Laughter ]
I'm a Cavalier! I would like
to make a phone call!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
They're beautiful dogs.
-Thanks.
-Thank you so much.
It's so great to see you.
-It's so good do see you.
-That's Olivia Munn, everybody
[ Cheers and applause ]